Từ cố gọi, tìt tôi đồng bảo và cự chỉ cả nước. Trước dụng nặng nè,
nhưng đây về văn, chính phủ nhập y hành hình của trong hài sau,
hành hình của trong và mốt, tí thức sâu sắc chắc gẹp của mình,
trước nhân dân, tại luôn thấm nần lời rại của chủ tịch của chính mình,
chính phủ ta là chính phủ của nhân dân.
Chỉ có một mục đích là ra sức phục sợ lời ec của nhân dân.
Vôi xin ở sẽ cùng tập tệ chính phủ, các mộng ngành,
biệt vương loạn kết một lòng.
Quết tâm đều đất nước mất và hành loạn phát triển mất phá,
gọ mạnh, phổn vuyền, văn muyền, hành phục.
Với chất chọng cảm ơn và kính mong tiếp tục dạng được sự lạnh đạo xấu sắc,
hưởng phuyên của bán chắc hành chung lên đạn.
Chực tiếp là bầu chí chỉ, bán biệt vóa đồng chí tàu biệt,
chủ tính nước tố lâm.
Sự quan thầm có bị ủng hộ của các đồng chín quyền lạnh đọng đạn.
Nhà nước, sự vối hợp đồng hành giám sát tối cao hiệu quả của khối.
Sự vối hợp chặt chạy của mặt chạy của các tổ chức chí chị xác hội.
Sự vối hợp sự uống hộ, tinh tưởng và thân ra tích cửa,
của tọn tệ đồng bàu, chính xí cả nước,
cùng có đồng người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài và mạnh mẹ của tế.